TELLING HIM YOU ARE THE FATHER.
SO DO YOU WANT TO HEAR A FUNNY
OPINION?
THAT DON LEMMON DOESN'T DO
OPINIONS.
>> I DON'T DO OPINION.
THE DIFFERENCE FOR ME IS I DO
POINT OF VIEW.
SO I'M GIVING MY POINT OF VIEW
AS AN AMERICAN, AS A BLACK MAN
WHO HAPPENS TO BE GAY, BUT I'M
ALSO -- I ALSO REPRESENT CNN AND
SO I MUST TELL THE TRUTH, AND IF
I DON'T, IF MY FACTS ARE WRONG,
THEN I HAVE TO CLARIFY IT AT
HAVE TO COME ON TELEVISION AND
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE AND SAY I GOT
THAT WRONG.
>> THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED.
SO HE'S TELLING YOU WHAT HE
BASES HIS OPINIONS OFF OF AT THE
SAME TIME HE TELLS YOU HE
DOESN'T GIVE OPINIONS, JUST
POINT OF VIEW!
LOOK UP WHAT POINT OF VIEW
MEANS.
IT MEANS OPINION!
BUT LET'S BE HONEST I'M A CNN'S
FACTS ARE MUCH LIKE THEIR
OPINIONS IN THAT THEY AREN'T
FACTS.
AND SERIOUSLY, DON LEMMON
DOESN'T DO OPINIONS?
THE OLIVE GARDEN DOESN'T DO
BREADSTICKS.
AND RIOTS ARE PEACEFUL AND CRIME
ISN'T EXPLODING AND KAT TIMPF
ISN'T HAMMERED OFF COPY TONER
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S TRUE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
OPINIONS.
OPINIONS ARE LIKE A HOLES,
EVERYONE HAS ONE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
A HOLES WITH OPINIONS?
THEY PROBABLY WORK AT CNN.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
IMAGINE TAKING ANYTHING THAT
LEMMON SAYS AS FACT.
I THINK CNN ONCE DID A
COMMERCIAL ON THAT.
>> THIS IS AN APPLE.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT TRY TO TELL
YOU THAT IT'S A BANANA.
THEY MIGHT SCREAM "BANANA,
BANANA, BANANA" OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY MIGHT PUT BANANA IN ALL
CAPS.
YOU MIGHT EVEN START TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A BANANA.
>> Greg: MUCH LIKE BRIAN
SELTZER'S HAIRLINE, THAT HAS NOT
AGED WELL.
AND NEITHER HAS LEMMON 'A
SO-CALLED FACTS, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS UNHINGED BABBLE PUKE.
>> YOU ARE THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
ACT LIKE IT.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A FRAUD AND A
CON MAN.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
A LOT OF US ALREADY KNEW THAT.
>> IF YOU VOTED FOR TRUMP, YOU
VOTED FOR THE PERSON WHO THE
CLAN SUPPORTED.
YOU VOTED FOR THE PERSON WHO
NAZIS SUPPORT.
THEY LIKE THE RACISM, THEY LIKE
THE MISOGYNY.
THEY LIKE ALL OF IT, BECAUSE IF
THEY DIDN'T, THEY WOULDN'T
SUPPORT HIM.
>> YEAH, DEMOCRATIC CITIES ARE
IN CHAOS RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE YOUR
COUNTRY AWAY AND THEY'RE TAKING
DOWN THE STATUES AND CRIME IS
RISING.
OH, MY GOSH, IT'S SO BAD AND
DEFUNDING POLICE --
[EXHALES]
>> Greg: BIDEN JUST DID A
PRESSER ON THE CRIME WAVE,
BUDDY.
IF YOU BROUGHT THIS GUY WITHIN A
MILE OF A LIE DETECTOR, IT WOULD
EXPLODE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT MANY BAD
OPINIONS SINCE THE INITIAL
REVIEWS OF THIS HIT SHOW.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THOSE
PEOPLE?
SO WHY IS HE SO DEFENSIVE ABOUT
EXPOSING OPINIONS?
IT SEEMS LIKE A CENTRAL PART OF
HIS IDENTITY, HIS EMOTIONAL
ASSESSMENT OF STUFF.
WHY CAN'T HE SAY HI, I'M DON
LEMMON AND I HAVE MORE OPINIONS
THAN A METH-ADDLED CABDRIVER?
INSTEAD WE HAVE TO LAUGH AT HIS
NIGHTLY DENIALS.
AFTER ME HE'S THE FUN'S
LATE-NIGHT SHOW ON TV.
PERHAPS IT'S A DEFENSIVE
RESPONSE TO OUR ACCURATE
CRITICISM OF CNN, AND WE ARE
ONLY TRYING TO HELP THEM.
A STRONG CNN MAKES FOR A
STRONGER FOX NEWS.
COMPETITION BUILD CHARACTER.
IT'S WHY MY DEBATE COACH WOULD
MAKE ME WRESTLE HIM FOR PENCILS.
THEY WERE ALWAYS IN HIS FRONT
POCKET.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
SO WITH A WEAK ADVERSARY LIKE
CNN, IT'S HARDER TO BUILD YOUR
OWN MUSCLES.
IT'S LIKE THE GYM, YOU NEED
HEAVYWEIGHTS TO BUILD STRENGTH
AND CNN IS LIKE THOSE STRETCH
BANS OLD LADIES USE IN ARTHRITIS
COMMERCIALS.
AND LIKE THOSE BANDS, YOU CAN
ONLY STRETCH THE TRUTH SO FAR
BEFORE IT BREAKS.
BUT AT THIS POINT IT'S ALMOST
UNFAIR TO COMMENT ON CNN.
IT'S LIKE BAD MOUTHING THE
DECEASED AT A FUNERAL.
BUT THEY DESERVE IT.
THEY REFUSE TO ADMIT THEY ARE
AGENDA-DRIVEN AT THE AGENDA IS
TO STOKE ANGER BETWEEN CITIZENS
IN ORDER TO KEEP EYEBALLS GLUED
TO THEIR MISERY FAST.
THE FACT THAT THEIR RATINGS ARE
LOWER THAN A SNAKE'S KNOTS
SHOULD BE GOOD NEWS FOR ALL OF
US.
STILL, THEY MUST MAINTAIN THE
BELIEF THAT THEY SPEAK THE TRUTH
BECAUSE EVERYTHING ELSE THEY DO
IS BUILT ON IT.
SNAKES DO HAVE NTUS
IF YOU LIE ALL THE TIME AND THEN
YOU TELL THE TRUTH, HALF OF THE
CNN VIEWERS WILL SUDDENLY FIGURE
OUT THAT YOU WERE LYING TO THEM
BEFORE, SO THEY TURN YOU OFF AND
BOOM, THERE GOES HALF THEIR
AUDIENCE, WHICH IS ROUGHLY THE
SIZE OF PETE HEGSETH'S FAMILY.
LAST WEEK I POINTED OUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US AND THE
DECEPTIVE CONS AT CNN.
WE MAKE IT CLEAR WHO IS GIVING
AN OPINION AND WHO IS REPORTING
A STORY.
TAKE ME AND BILL HEMMER...
TO ARUBA.
HE'S A NEWS GUY WHO DELIVERS THE
PRODUCT STRAIGHTER THAN PERINO'S
TEETH.
I'M AN OPINION GUY WHO LOOKS
GREAT IN A PASTEL SPEEDO.
FOLLOW ME ON INSTAGRAM.
HOW DOES DON LEMON SEE THIS?
>> SO THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT I'M DOING AND WHAT
SOMEONE COME AS YOU MENTIONED,
OVER AT FOX NEWS IS DOING.
I'M OPERATING FROM A PLACE OF
TRUTH, IT'S ALL BASED IN FACT
AND IT'S ALL BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE THAT'S OUT THERE.
>> YEAH, THE KEYWORD COME OUT
THERE.
IT'S A DODGE.
HE CAN LIE BECAUSE THE LIGHT
COMES FROM THE TRUTH THAT'S OUT
THERE AND IT'S THAT DEFENSE THAT
HAS ALLOWED CNN TO PUSH
DESTRUCTIVE BILE ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT THE
DECIMATION OF OUR CITIES DUE TO
THE LEFT-WING POLICIES TNN
PARADES AS PROGRESS, BUT IMAGINE
IF CNN HADN'T EMBRACED THE
POLICE IS RACIST THEME AND HAD
LOOKED AT THE DATA.
IF I COULD DO IT, SO COULD
LEMON, BUT HE DIDN'T COME UP
BECAUSE IF HE DID, ZUCKER WOULD
CAN HIM QUICKER THAN CLEANED
PEACHES.
IF THEY HADN'T DISPLAYED --
THERE ARE BLACK AND BROWN TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, BUT THEY DIDN'T
COUNT, AT LEAST TO LEMON.
IMAGINE IF THEY SAW HOW MUCH
DIVISIVE OPINIONS CREATED A
CLIMATE THAT PIT PEOPLE AGAINST
EACH OTHER, CULMINATING IN
BILLIONS OF DAMAGES AND RIOTING.
OH HOW THEY LAUGHED AT THAT
CRIME, YOU SAW THAT.
IF ONLY THEY HADN'T WAITED UNTIL
IT FINALLY AFFECTED BIDEN'S
ELECTION CHANCES THAT THEY TOOK
THE BLOODSHED SERIOUSLY.
PALPABLE SUBVERSION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADING TO
REDUCTION OF POLICE INTERACTIONS
IN COMMUNITIES THAT NEEDED THEIR
HELP THE MOST.
THE RESULTS, A MASSIVE SPIKE IN
SHOOTING A MURDER, THE DEATH OF
INNOCENT MINORITY SINCE CITIES
LEFT TO ROT BY THE LEFT WHO TOOK
THEIR CUES FROM...
CNN.
BUT I GUESS THAT'S JUST HIS
OPINION, RIGHT?
BUT IT'S AN OPINION ARISING FROM
TRUTH, FROM FACTS.
I MEAN, IF LEMON CAN SAY THAT,
SO CAN I.
BUT AT LEAST I'M HONEST ENOUGH
TO SAY THAT IT'S MY OPINION.
TIME FOR LEMON TO DO THE SAME.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S AGHAST!
HER BICEPS ARE REGISTERED WITH
CROSSFIT AND THE NRA, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
HE WAS AWARDED THE BRONZE STAR
AND THAT'S ALSO HIS NICKNAME AT
THE TANNING SALON, FOX & FRIENDS
WEEKEND COHOST, PETE HEGSETH!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
SHE'S LOUDER THAN A GARBAGE
DISPOSAL FOR LOVE ANGRY GHOSTS,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
IF HE HOLLERS CANNONBALL,
THERE'S ABOUT TO BE A TSUNAMI.
MY SIDEKICK AND A HOST OF
[INDISCERNIBLE] ON FOX NATION,
TYRUS!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SO THAT THE FIRST
TIME I'VE BEEN UNDER INSTAGRAM.
YOU WORK OUT LIKE A DEMON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS FOR CHECKING ME
OUT.
>> Greg: THINK I LEARNED A
LOT.
I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT HOW TO DO
MY TRICEPS BETTER.
ALWAYS FEEL LIKE THAT THE LEGACY
MEDIA IS BASED ON AN ADOLESCENT
IDEA, ALMOST LIKE FROM A
FRESHMAN IN HIGH SCHOOL, THAT
THEY KNOW THE TRUTH AND NO ONE
ELSE DOES AND THEN THAT MEANS
THAT THEY CAN READ EVERYBODY
ELSE'S MIND AND THAT'S WHAT
CNN -- THAT'S WHY CNN CAN
DEMONIZE EVERYONE.
>> YEAH, WELL, IT'S VERY CLEAR,
MAYBE THEY DON'T CALL IT
OPINION.
IT MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE IT IS
OBVIOUSLY LIKE LEFT-WING
PROPAGANDA, THAT THEY CONTINUE
TO PUSH OUT THERE, IT'S VERY
CLEAR TO ANYONE THAT'S BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND CNN IS
DEFINITELY PART OF THAT IS LIKE
THE MARKETING ARM FOR THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WANT THEM TO PUT OUT THERE AND
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR WHEN YOU
WALKED ON THE STREET, YOU CAN
SEE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BOUGHT
INTO THE PROPAGANDA AND SEE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FREETHINKERS, WHO
ARE CRITICAL THINKERS WHO HAVE
CLEARLY NOT BOUGHT INTO IT AND
BY THE WAY, I THINK THEY ARE
PLAYING THEIR HAND A LITTLE TOO
FAR EACH AND EVERY DAY AND I
THINK PEOPLE ASTERN TO WAKE UP
AND SAY SOMETHING ISN'T RIGHT,
BECAUSE AFTER ALL, WE SEE ALL
THE THINGS THAT THEY WERE
CONTINUING TO BE WRONG ABOUT
COME OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Greg: AND THE THING IS,
PETE, HE SAID LIKE WHEN I'M
WRONG, I'LL ADMIT IT.
HE NEVER ADMITTED HE WAS WRONG
ABOUT ANYTHING, ESPECIALLY THE
RIOTS THAT HE MOCKED, THE
VIOLENCE IN THE BLACK ON BLACK
CRIME.
HE MOCKED IT.
HE NEVER CAME BACK AND SAID BOY,
I REALLY SCREWED UP.
INSTEAD, HE SAID THAT IT'S
AFFECTING BIDEN'S CHANCES IN THE
ELECTION, WHICH, YOU KNOW, AS WE
KNOW, SOME ELECTION, RIGHT,
PETE?
[CACKLE]
>> LET'S SEE THAT AGAIN IN 2024.
THE ENTIRE PREMISES BASED ON THE
FACT THAT HE IS SMART AND YOU'RE
DONE.
AND AS A RESULT, IF HE ADMITS
THAT HE'S WRONG, HE'S GOT TO
ADMIT THAT HE'S NOT AS SMART AS
HE SAYS AND HE DOESN'T GET TO
TELL YOU HIS POINT OF VIEW THAT
ISN'T OPINION.
BY THE WAY, HE WENT FROM CNN TO
PBS SO THAT HE COULD GO THE ONLY
PLACE LOWER RATED THAN CNN.
TO DO THIS INTERVIEW.
>> Greg: POSTED BY -- AND THAT
WAS MARGARET HOOVER, WHO IS
MARRIED TO JOHN AVALON, WHO IS
ONE OF THE LOUDEST, MOST
OBNOXIOUS HACKS ON CNN.
>> PROBABLY ON TWITTER THAN AS
WELL.
THE WHOLE THING IS WE
ULTIMATELY -- DON'T LIE TO ME.
THAT'S ALL I WANT A TV.
GREG GUTFELD WILL COME UP AND
SAY THIS IS MY POINT OF VIEW,
THIS IS MY OPINION.
WHEN YOU STAND UP AND SAY NO, I
AM OBJECTIVE, JUST THE FACTS,
JUST THE SCIENCE, JUST THE
TRUTH, AND YOU CAN SEE RIGHT
THROUGH IT -- THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
TURN THE CHANNEL.
PEOPLE WOULD RATHER WATCH MSNBC
WHERE THE GOT A POINT OF VIEW,
I'M GOING TO TELL IT LIKE IT IS,
JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY RACHEL
MADDOW IS A PRO AND I MAY
DISAGREE WITH EVERYTHING, BUT
SHE'S NOT A PHONY.
TYRUS, IT'S LIKE WHERE LEVEL OF
AWARENESS WHERE CNN IS AT THIS
WEIRD THING WHERE THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY KNOW THE TRUTH.
AS YOU GET OLDER, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET WISDOM WHERE YOU
KNOW THAT TRUTH ISN'T -- THAT'S
NOT HOW IT WORKS.
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN LOOK AT CNN
AND YOU CAN LOOK AT FOX NEWS AND
YOU CAN LOOK AT MSNBC AND SEE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
YOU CAN BE ABOVE IT.
>> I'M ABOVE IT NATURALLY,
GREAT.
I KNOW BEING ABOVE THINGS IS NEW
FOR YOU.
BY THE WAY, ONLY YOU COULD SEE
IF A SNAKE HAS NUTS.
IT'S NOT BE SO QUICK TO JUDGE.
HOLD ON HERE, IF YOU CAN SAY
POINT OF VIEW AND OPINION, I
MEAN -- I DON'T MURDER, I TAKE
LIFE.
YOU CAN JUST KIND OF SPLIT --
LET'S NOT BE SO -- IT'S ALWAYS
SAFE -- WHAT HE'S BASICALLY
SAYING IS I'M NOT WRONG AND IF I
AM, IT'S FROM MY POINT OF VIEW
BECAUSE I'M COMING FROM A PLACE
OF TRUTH, WHICH MEANS THAT I
CAN'T BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANYTHING I SAY, SO IF YOU GIVE
AN OPINION, YOU HAVE TO OWN IT
AND IT TAKES COURAGE TO GIVE AN
OPINION.
TO SIT UP HERE, ESPECIALLY YOUR
STATURE AND THOSE SOCKS, FOR YOU
TO SAY THE THINGS THAT YOU WANT
TO SAY.
LISTEN, I'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE SHE'S GOING TO SNAP AND
I'M NOT GOING TO STOP HER.
>> Greg: ABOUT MY SOCKS KIM >>
EVERY WEEK YOU KEEP THROWING
LITTLE JABS AT KAT AND I'M
TELLING YOU, IT'S BUILDING.
IT'S BUILDING, AND WHEN SHE
GIVES YOU HER POINT OF VIEW,
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO HEAR MY
OPINION.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, KAT, ARE
YOU A DON LEMON FAN?
>> NO.
>> Greg: ARE YOU A -- DO YOU
NOTICE THAT THEIR ENTIRETY -- I
GUESS THEIR ENTIRE PREMISE IS
BASED ON KNOWING WHAT YOU THINK.
LIKE IF YOU SAY, KAT, TWO CNN,
I'M NOT RACIST, THEY WOULD
DISAGREE AND GO I KNOW YOU ARE.
>> I THINK IF ANYONE KNEW WHAT I
WAS THINKING OF HER, I WOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED IN SOCIETY.
BUT I JUST THINK IT'S SO
INTERESTING THAT ANYBODY WOULD
EVER TRUST ANY HUMAN AND SAY
YES, WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
COMPLETE FACT, BECAUSE A LOT OF
US ARE NOT PERFECT AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE -- SOMEONE CAN TELL YOU
ONE THING AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
YOU SPEND SOME TIME HIDING IN
THE BUSHES AND YOU SEE SOMETHING
COMPLETE DIFFERENT.
YOU CAN'T COMPLETELY -- EVEN
FANCY YOURSELF -- HE IS
REMARKABLY BAD AT IT AND HE
DOESN'T EVEN TRY.
EVERYTHING IS AN OPINION.
EVERYTHING IS, YOU KNOW, CLEARLY
HIS BIAS IS VERY, VERY, VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT.
BUT TO EVEN THINK THAT HE WOULD
BE CAPABLE OF THAT IS A CREEPY
LEVEL OF NARCISSISM.
>> Greg: I ALWAYS USE MY
EXAMPLE OF MY SHIFT ON
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRETTY DRASTIC
AND IT WAS BECAUSE OF MY
COGNITIVE BIASES.
I'M AWARE OF WHEN -- I'M AWARE
HOW WE MANUFACTURE OUR OWN
TRUTHS.
WE MANUFACTURE OUR OWN TRUTH
EVERY DAY AND THEN WE COME TO
BELIEVE IT AND THEN WE SAY BUT
IT'S THE TRUTH.
WE FORGET THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
MANUFACTURED IT.
>> LIKE HOW I USED TO DRINK
BEFORE WORK AND NOW THAT I KNOW
I CAN GET HIGH OFF COPY TONER,
I'M GOING TO SAVE A LOT OF
MONEY.